so insightful moment of the day courtesy
of a conversation with my friend
Elizabeth so this is great we should
share this with the world so we were
just talking about entrace meant like
aesthetic entrace meant with you when
you succumb to a beautiful moment when
you're lost on a walk in the woods when
you're experiencing forest bathing when
you're in an area that is congruent with
appreciation of beauty a place that is
aesthetically relevant a novel when
you're in these moments there is a
desire for agency there's a desire to be
a co participant in the creation of
beauty there's a desire in a way to be
an alchemist to be a magician to be a
shaman to be a Dream Weaver an example
of that would be to want to add a
soundtrack to this moment to play a song
during this moment to add a musical
score that enhances the power and the
melodic intensity and the subjective
intensity of this circumstance so then
we started thinking well isn't that what
filmmakers do right when a director is
sitting in the editing room and he's
setting the movie to a particular
soundtrack he's essentially a shaman
right did you did you know film making
directors are forms of I would say that
filmmaking is a form of shamanism and
directors are Dreamweavers directors are
literally dream weavers I'm imagining a
director in the editing room framing a
shot and saying play this song at this
moment as the Sun starts to shine and
the character experiences ecstatic
illumination and then that gets that
spills through the screen and onto the
viewer and then if the viewer of the
film has an ecstatic experience has an
experience of illumination when they
watch the film then the director gets
the satisfaction the existential
realization that he is a Dream Weaver
that he is a shaman that filmmaking is a
form of shamanism and again the director
is the Dream Weaver and I think that for
me when I make these videos even
capturing this moment I'm trying to
convey this objective aesthetic
intensity of this container that we're
creating the container of course of two
cool friends hanging out in nature right
so you have this container you have this
moment I'm conveying how it feels and
then I would add music to it later and
then I would lay images on the screen
that are metaphorically congruent with
the stream of consciousness that's
coming out of my mind and so then people
have an experience afterwards that is
not just what we're going through
but it's what we're
going through feels like from within
enhanced by music and imagery this is
the goal of the artist to step into the
new space the unknown you know take that
all in let it reverberate through his
consciousness decide how he could tweak
and enhance it make it better and then
bring that back and then capture that so
thought of the day cinema is a form of
shamanism right filmmaking is shamanism
and the director is a Dream Weaver you
agree thank you for listening this today